[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
AARON ZEMACH: Awesome.
And now everyone, again, let's
welcome to Google John Linnell
and John Flansburgh,
They Might Be Giants.
[APPLAUSE]
So I saw that music video for
the first time this morning.
It was fantastic.
And it's got me thinking.
I'm curious a little bit about
when you are working on a music
video or you want a music
video for a song, what's
the collaboration process
like for you and the director?
Do you send them the song and
sort of give them free range?
Is there a
back-and-forth involved?
JOHN LINNELL: It's
normally that.
I mean, the best results,
it seems like, we get
are from people who
are uncontrollable.
And even for the stuff
we've done for kids,
it's just we've gotten
spectacularly great results
when the people get to do
whatever they want and they are
bringing all this
stuff to the song that
was not in our minds
whatsoever, just utterly--
stuff that makes our
jaws hit the floor.
That's always a
great treat for us
because normally, we're really
used to what we're doing.
And our ideas are
completely familiar to us
by the time we've ironed
them into a product.
So it's a really wonderful treat
when somebody makes a video.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah,
that's awesome.
And so this year, you're doing
another Dial-A-Song, new song
released every week online.
And all of them are going to
have a music video attached
to it, as well.
And you did this
previously in 2015.
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: So
to me, it sounds
like releasing 52 songs in one
year is just this grueling--
JOHN LINNELL: It's a bad idea.
AARON ZEMACH: --process, yeah?
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: So what made you
want to return through it again
in 2017 for a second go?
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
I can't remember.
It does seem like a bad idea.
The truth is-- the
origin story of the band
is really wrapped up in
this Dial-A-Song service
that we had that was
just a phone machine.
And that was a lot easier than
the 52 songs in a year thing,
actually, to be
perfectly honest.
Because the Three-card
Monte trick of that
was that we had a suitcase
full of 40 cassettes and we
would just shuffle them around.
And some things would
be in order to end--
we would bring in
new songs, take out
the really, miserably bad ones.
And if we went away
on tour, my landlady
would come in and change them.
And it was manageable.
This thing is a
little bit more--
the 2015 Dial-A-Song project
was a little bit more
about facing the way the world
kind of takes in music now.
I mean, social media is
discovery for a lot of people.
The only way they
find out about things
is through Facebook or Twitter
or Instagram or whatever.
So if you're not kind of feeding
that manic beast all the time,
you're really just
talking to your front row.
Ultimately, I guess, we
are always on a quest
to find more people to be
interested in what we're doing.
I mean, we've been doing
this for so long that we have
to-- we have to find--
we need more people.
AARON ZEMACH: And
so your strategy
sort of has been adapting,
over the years of your career,
in new ways to find
that new audience?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah.
I mean, by being able to
say, on Facebook on any given
Wednesday, here's
a new song, that
seems like a much
more interesting way
of keeping it going.
AARON ZEMACH: So
one of the reasons
that I've been sharing a few
of the songs that have come out
have been previews for the
new album, "I Like Fun".
And they have, if you listen
to the lyrical content,
sounded anything
but being about fun.
It's a pretty stark contrast.
So just because it's the
world that we live in,
and it's an album that must
have come together in 2017,
was that in any part
influencing the tone?
I mean, you've
always been writing
music that has
some darker tones,
but has the world of
2017 at all influenced
what became "I Like Fun"?
JOHN LINNELL: I think
in a general way.
But I mean, they're not
specifically topical songs.
And there's a lot of
death imagery, which
is not particularly topical.
Any old time is
good for a death--
you know.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah, yeah.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah.
I mean, one of the things
that does sort of come out,
ultimately, when you stack
up a big pile of songs,
is you realize how much
you're in the zeitgeist.
I don't think you'd sit down
write a song thinking about,
I'm going to write
something about right now.
But when we do--
I remember at the
height of the Bush era,
we made a record, an album that
sounded extremely dystopian,
for lack of a less
political word.
AARON ZEMACH: Sure.
So this is kind of
an unfair question
because it's like saying,
where do your ideas come from?
But after--
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Oh,
we've got answers.
AARON ZEMACH: OK, great.
Well I was going to say after
20 albums, how do you-- is it
the zeitgeist-- or where are the
places where you keep drawing
inspiration for
songs, especially
since the range of They
Might Be Giants song content
tends to be a little bit
wider than your standard pop?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: It's right at
the bottom of a cup of coffee.
[LAUGHTER]
We are truly
addicted to caffeine.
And it is--
I don't know.
JOHN LINNELL: There
isn't an answer.
I mean, in a way,
if there were, I
think we'd be pretty
bored with ourselves.
If we had a calculus
for writing songs,
I think it would be
pretty obvious that that's
what we were doing, and we'd
be disappointed in ourselves.
But we're really--
I mean, the job gets
harder every year.
We are really casting
around all the time
for something new and
meaningful to say in a song.
And that doesn't mean--
I mean, they're
not these sort of--
I suppose it sounds
wrong to say they're
these deeply personal
statements that we're
saying something about.
But they are meaningful.
And we want to have an idea.
That's the point of the
song, is to have a good idea
and put it out there and have
it be fresh and, obviously, not
repeat ourselves.
I think the thing about what
we're doing is, at this point,
it's really obvious
to our audience,
or to anyone who
hears one of our songs
who's familiar with us,
it's obvious it's us.
It's like, clearly, this
is the kind of thing we do.
But we're very
scrupulously trying
to write a new thing each time.
And there's no really
simple way to do that.
There's no formula, sadly.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
At some point, we
realized we were
running out of nouns.
And we sort of gave
ourselves permission
to use the same nouns again.
JOHN LINNELL: Adverbs.
AARON ZEMACH: Recycle nouns.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Moving on to adverbs.
AARON ZEMACH: Right.
So I guess when you're
putting your tour together
for the "I Like Fun"
tour, is that something
you're thinking about?
How the new material is going to
fit with the old material, how
everything fits together?
JOHN LINNELL: Sure, yeah.
Well, I mean, the tour is
the beautiful part for us
because we have 30
years of backlog.
So we have a huge amount
of stuff to choose from.
That's the easy part.
We've got so many songs
we can just make up--
it's Flansburgh's
job-- and I'm not
trying to say it's
an easy job-- but he
does have an enormous
backlog of material.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: It's
a huge responsibility.
JOHN LINNELL: It's a
big responsibility.
The weight on John's shoulders
is unbearable, I know that.
But it's nice for us, I think,
that we have so many songs
that we can play songs that
we haven't played in a decade.
It's very fresh and fun to pull
out something that's from long
ago that we're--
I don't remember
having this idea,
but it's exciting to
experience it again.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Like on this tour,
we're doing a song-- we just
got a trumpet player full-time
in the band for the
whole touring act.
We've worked with horn
players in New York,
but it's expensive to have a
whole horn section come out
with you.
So we figured out, we can clear
out the junk bunk in the bus
and get a trumpet
player in there.
And it allows us to do a bunch
of songs that have brass in it.
So it opens up a whole other
kind of song arrangement
that we haven't had before.
Like, we're doing a song
called "Hey, Mr. DJ, I
Thought You Said
We Had a Deal" that
was like a B-side to
"Don't Let's Start."
And I mean, obviously, for
the people in the audience,
there's like a front
row and a back row,
and there are very
different kinds of--
and there are people who
have been dragged there
by their friends, who are
just only so interested
in what you're doing.
But it is exciting to be able
to pull out a song like that
and have people in
the front really
go like, whoa, rather
than just have it
be like marching out
with your old favorites.
AARON ZEMACH: Sure.
So it sounds like it's
almost this new phase
of the band, where there's this
whole catalog to draw from.
I'm curious how that differs
from when you were first
touring or first starting out.
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: And I'd
especially be interested-- like,
in New York, since
you are highly
associated with the New York
music scene, clearly a lot
different now from the 1980s.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Well, the
1980s was a really unusual time,
especially in New York, because
we came up in this moment
where there were a tremendous
number of gatekeepers
protecting the things
that made a lot of money.
We were very aware
that superstar acts
were trying to hold onto their
market share very, very hard.
So even just breaking
into the local club scene
was very-- there was a lot of
folded arms and a lot of people
saying no.
And it was very hard
to get past that.
I think in 2017, 2018,
it's almost impossible
to understand how
democratized culture has
become because of the internet.
People just have to like
it and it will suddenly
become very popular.
There were so many people
in the way of anyone even
having any idea of what
you were doing then.
You couldn't even
get a gig in a club
unless you fit into
the idea of that club.
So we're the guys in
They Might Be Giants.
What club do we work at?
JOHN LINNELL: Right, right.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: You know?
But fortunately, there was
this little cultural bubble
in the East Village which was
this very transgressive, very
druggie scene.
But the main thing
about the East Village
scene that was kind
of fascinating-- this
is 1984, '85, '86.
The clubs were called
The Pyramid Club, 8BC,
[? Durenko, ?] places that most
people have never heard of,
but they were an incredible
phenomenon at the time.
And this is at a time when the
"New York Times" and the "New
Yorker" would not cover
shows below 14th Street--
no reviews of anything
happening, unless it
was at the Village Gate.
So you're basically talking
about this extraordinary period
of siloed-off culture.
So this bohemian New
York scene was happening.
And their emphasis-- and it
was very clear from club owner
to club owner--
that they only were
interested in original acts.
So it was suddenly,
instead of being
in some college town where
the guy's like, "why don't you
do Blondie songs?"
all of a sudden, we
were in this situation
where our originality
could really shine
and it was really emphasized.
JOHN LINNELL: Right.
The other thing, the weird
thing about that situation
was we were playing in clubs
that weren't music clubs,
they were performance art clubs.
So we were the normal thing
that was being brought in--
[LAUGHTER] just
to play some songs
in between some
unspeakably weird,
impossible-to-describe
thing that was going on.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
It's hard to imagine
a time when performance
art was the new thing that
was happening.
Because it really
is indescribable.
I think Daryl Hannah
in "Legal Eagles"
is the only actual cultural
document of performance art
that made it through.
AARON ZEMACH: So now in
this democratized era,
how do you fit into that
as a more established act,
but with a very
specific audience?
JOHN LINNELL: We are a
brand unto ourselves now,
in which we can't kind of--
that's just the way it is now.
So I think we're completely
also in a different position
from a band that's
starting out now
where, I don't know how
you establish yourself,
at this point.
We are managing to garner
new, younger people,
but we also have this fan base.
So there's a kind of
inertia to it that we enjoy.
What advice would you give
to the artists starting out?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Save yourself.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
We just started doing
interviews again
because we're doing
this album and tour,
and somebody was asking me if
we considered ourselves a cult
band.
And I realized, I don't
even know if that's--
actually, I'm so value-neutral
on the idea of what a cult
band--
like, is that really good?
Is that really bad?
JOHN LINNELL: Right.
What should I answer?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah.
If it's good, yeah,
sure, we're a cult band.
I mean, I think anything that's
been around for a long time
has an established audience.
And the only problem
that we have is we--
I don't know.
I always felt like we're just
another thing in the world.
We don't have to be the
center of your life.
I think people tend
to think of bands
that are left of center
as somehow like these--
as cults.
I guess I feel
like I would prefer
not to be thought of as a cult.
JOHN LINNELL: Well, I think,
to me, the obvious distinction
between us and a cult
band is that we don't
represent a lifestyle, I hope.
Because that would be weird.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: This sweater
represents a lifestyle.
[LAUGHTER]
But that was my personal
lifestyle choice.
AARON ZEMACH: Stanley Kubrick's
personal style choices?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yes, exactly.
But I was going to say,
there was a time somewhere
in the '90s where I could see--
we were playing some big
festival-y kind of show,
and there were two people--
two men-- in the near-front
row of the audience.
And one guy was wearing
a Pearl Jam shirt
and the other guy was
wearing a Pearl Jam shirt.
And over the course--
we were doing a set we
were very familiar with,
so my mind had time to wander.
And I realized, at
a certain point,
one guy was actually wearing the
shirt ironically and the other
guy wasn't.
[LAUGHTER]
And I sort of felt like,
that's kind of a good place
to be in the culture--
JOHN LINNELL: That is the scope.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: --the world.
Dudes who wear Pearl
Jam shirts of all kinds.
It's like a diversity move.
AARON ZEMACH: Right.
We had some interesting chats
earlier about technology,
since we are here at Google and
we have the self-driving car
and everything.
And I was looking--
it's what we have.
[LAUGHTER]
I was looking--
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I thought
my car was self-driving.
AARON ZEMACH: On the They
Might Be Giants Wiki,
I was looking up earlier just
some of the different ways
that you've used the internet,
over the course of your career,
as a way to distribute music.
So in 1999, you
released an album only
on the internet, back
when that was still
a bold, newsworthy move.
In 2003, you had a They Might Be
Giants streaming internet radio
service.
You started podcasting in
2005, long before "Serial"
or any of that took off.
So I'm curious what music
distribution technologies
you're interested in today
that, in six or seven years,
everyone's just going to think,
oh, this is the way to do it.
JOHN LINNELL: CD-ROM, I think.
We're very exciting.
AARON ZEMACH: It's
coming back around?
JOHN LINNELL: Yes.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: It's
coming back, man.
Don't give up.
LaserDiscs.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Actually, CD-ROMs
are the only emerging
technology that we completely
skipped over, I
think because we were
right at the point of our deal
with Electro where we realized
that this could be our royalty.
JOHN LINNELL: We were
too stingy, basically.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah,
it was just like,
we don't want to be the R&D
department for Warner Brothers.
But I think we're pretty
agnostic about emerging
technology.
If there's something
coming up, it's really
a way to have people hear us.
It's just another way to get
access to another audience.
In the past couple
of months, I've
been actively working
on Spotify playlists.
And sometimes,
you start to think
you're talking to yourself,
but then you realize, oh,
hey, 250 people are
subscribing to this.
And that means they're
passing it along to x number
more people.
And if you're open to it,
it's available to you.
I think the internet
thing was something--
doing music distribution so
early on in the internet,
I think really made us aware
of what a lost opportunity
the early internet was.
The whole Napster moment was
such a missed opportunity.
There was so much money being
made in the music business
without the internet that they
just were really at loggerheads
about how to do it.
But it was obvious that it was
going to be the way that things
were going to go.
But nobody in the tall buildings
wanted to hear about it.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah, yeah.
Do you have ways that you
prefer to listen to your music--
streaming, vinyl,
or ways that you
think people should be listening
to They Might Be Giants music?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: The
mystery of silence?
John.
JOHN LINNELL: I feel pretty
dumb because I listen
I often listen on my laptop.
And it's like the worst,
absolutely the worst way
to reproduce music.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: John listens
to mixes of They Might Be Giants
on his laptop--
JOHN LINNELL: On my
laptop, that's true.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: --which
drives me insane.
JOHN LINNELL: The
thing you sent me,
I did listen to on speakers.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I know.
Well--
JOHN LINNELL: Because
you asked me to.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN LINNELL: But yeah.
I think, in a way, it's probably
not an accident because I've--
and you know this--
I've always had a kind
of slightly ouchy feeling
about the super high and the
super lows that were introduced
sometime in the 1980s.
Where, before that, I felt
like the band with the music--
JOHN FLANSBURGH: When sound
reproduction became better.
JOHN LINNELL: Became
unbearably good.
And before that, there
was a narrower range,
narrower bandwidth, to music.
And I felt like it was
in the right proportion
to my relationship with music.
And now it's like these super
tingly highs and super crazy--
I mean, I feel like such
an old man saying this.
But it's too much.
Actually, Bob Dylan
said something to that.
He was like, there's
just too much sound.
You can hear the song anymore.
AARON ZEMACH: Wow.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: And when you're
agreeing with Bob Dylan about--
JOHN LINNELL: You know
you're an old man.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: --about
audiophile stuff.
AARON ZEMACH: Perfect.
So in a few minutes,
we're going to open up
to questions from the room.
We have two
microphones if people
are interested in queuing up.
While people are
moving, I do have
another question that
I'm very curious about,
"SpongeBob the Musical".
So the score for
that is many artists
contributing different songs.
One is contributed
by the two of you.
"The New Yorker" said
that it was the standout
track from the show, alongside
John Legend and Cindy Lauper
and--
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Those are the facts.
AARON ZEMACH: Yes.
Actual-- how did the two of you
get involved in that project?
JOHN LINNELL: We were approached
by them, which was great.
And I think we were
given the choice
of two possible subjects.
We picked the
Squidward solo song.
And they just took exactly the
demo at pretty much verbatim.
And I would like to take credit
for the whole amazing success,
but I think they had the idea
of having the squid do a tap
dance with all four legs.
You have to see it in person.
It's insane.
It looks crazy.
And that wasn't us.
And that's a big part of why
that song just blows everyone
away, I think.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah.
They turned into an
enormous production number,
so it was nice to see our
thing get amplified that way.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah,
that's super cool.
So we have a question over here.
JOHN LINNELL: Hello.
AUDIENCE: So hi,
asking for a friend.
What's some good advice to be
excellent at parkour at 58?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Asking
for a friend, I like--
JOHN LINNELL: A friend, yes.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: --I like that.
You know, the song is very
much about a fantasy--
JOHN LINNELL: I thought
you wrote it about me?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I know it.
I'm 57.
JOHN LINNELL: I'm 58.
So I think it's about me.
I think the question
is addressed to me.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Please.
Please.
JOHN LINNELL: Calcium.
Drink a lot of milk
for your bones.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I'm
answering for a friend.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN LINNELL: Yes.
You know, shoulder
pads, I don't know.
I've never done it.
I have no idea.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: How
do people do parkour?
is my question.
Because it's like, when you
see best of parkour 2017,
it's just like being
inside a dream.
Also, how do you film parkour?
Where's that guy?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN LINNELL: We can just
leave those questions
as an exercise for the listener.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to follow
up on the "SpongeBob" question.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I thought
you were going to say I want
to follow up on the parkour.
AUDIENCE: I have answers if
you want to approach me later.
So Aaron was asking
you about, what's
the best medium to
listen to your music on?
And I feel like a
generation younger
than me learned about They
Might Be Giants through "Malcolm
in the Middle" and that theme
song, and now people are
learning through Broadway.
I'm curious what you
think about that,
and if you have any stories
about failed opportunities,
or songs you've
written that have--
the sitcom has been like, no,
that definitely doesn't work.
JOHN LINNELL: Well, how
brutally honest should we be?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Go for it.
JOHN LINNELL: We wrote a whole
raft of songs for the movie
"Coraline," which
only some of which
have ever seen the light of day.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I think 30
seconds of which were actually
in the movie.
JOHN LINNELL: Well, 30 seconds
of which were in the movie,
and then there's
another song that we
released on an album called
"Careful What You Pack".
But we wrote a ton
of other songs.
And it was kind of a
bittersweet experience
because I think part
of it was, we were just
producing all this
material and throwing it
to the director, Henry Selick.
And he is extremely true
blue in his creative process.
And I'm not just
saying that to be nice.
I really respect the guy.
But he basically felt like
this whole bunch of things
that we'd given him were not
going to work in his vision.
And there just wasn't
a way to make it work.
And it was upsetting
and sad for us,
but it's just the thing
about collaborating.
You know, it's just that's
what happens sometimes.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: And movies
are such a by-committee,
kind of like it's
easier for people
to prove their value by
saying no to something
than actually
producing something.
It was a weird kind of spanking
tunnel of an experience.
But it's interesting.
The "Malcolm in the Middle"
stuff, I feel like--
I never know-- there was
a period of time where
at 11 o'clock, there was a
rerun of the Mickey Mouse
show, "The Daily Show," and
"Malcolm in the Middle."
And I would just be
changing the channels
going like, wow, we are
completely dominating
this medium of television.
But at the same time,
they're such faceless jobs,
I don't think anybody--
with "The Daily
Show," the credit
ran once a week on
the Friday when it's
going [BUZZES], really fast.
That's the only time you would
ever see our name associated
with the show.
It's interesting to
do faceless stuff.
For years, we did music
for Diet Dr. Pepper.
And we did music for Dunkin'
Donuts for, like, four years.
And it was a super-fun
job and nobody
knew it was us, which
was kind of great.
JOHN LINNELL: I think
the Dunkin' one,
we were basically
hired to do us.
So the people who were
already familiar with us
could probably identify it.
My wife heard a commercial
and was like, oh, I know that.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Well, I
would hope your wife would--
JOHN LINNELL: She, at
least, identified us.
But yeah, we were partly
influenced, I think,
by stuff that we
saw on TV where we--
not until 20 years
later-- found out
who wrote the, whatever,
"Mission Impossible" theme
or something.
So it is a kind of work
that you can do, I think,
where you're not
going to get credit,
but you get the satisfaction
of doing a good job.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: And
you can explain yourself
to taxi drivers more.
JOHN LINNELL: Right, exactly.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Or
your mother's friends.
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
AARON ZEMACH: Just out of
curiosity, how many people here
knew that They Might
Be Giants did the theme
music for "The Daily Show"?
JOHN LINNELL: No one
is raising their hands.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: You mean,
you guys didn't put it
into slow-mo on Friday?
AARON ZEMACH: OK, over here.
JOHN LINNELL: First of
all, are you guys aware
that we wrote the
theme that-- when
your phone rings, that's us.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I am sorry.
I never heard of
you guys before.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN LINNELL: Not a problem.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: "Daily Show."
JOHN LINNELL: "Daily Show."
"Daily Show. iPhone
ring, that's us.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But I find you guys
to be very witty,
in contrast to your songs,
which are a bit dark.
JOHN LINNELL: Ah, yes.
Well, they're witty, as well.
They're just dark witty.
AUDIENCE: But you know, I
don't have a musical ear,
but my friend does.
And I wonder if you can
write a line, anything
that occurs in your
mind, and sign it
for me, if this is allowed?
AARON ZEMACH: Why don't we
circle around afterwards?
AUDIENCE: I have to
go for an interview.
JOHN LINNELL: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN LINNELL: Well.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I'll make
a little drawing for you.
AUDIENCE: Please
address it to Katie.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Katie?
With a C or a K?
AUDIENCE: K-A-D-I-E.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I-E, OK.
I'm going to make a
little like that and that.
Who else has got a question?
Because I can do this--
AARON ZEMACH: Let's go
over to this other mic
and have a question
while we wait.
AUDIENCE: So first, I was
texted by an old friend
today, a very old friend,
and he said, hey, guess what?
I'm going to make you feel old.
"Flood" was released
28 years ago today.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Oh,
I heard about that.
AUDIENCE: And I was like, what?
I'm going to go to a talk
by They Might Be Giants.
AARON ZEMACH: 20 years
ago today, January 8?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: Wow.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah.
They release the records they
don't believe in in January.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well, it was really
meaningful to my friend
and I. So that was an
interesting moment.
But I wanted to ask about
listening to music on laptops.
Because I read something
about Dial-A-Song
where you said
that forcing to be
audible and sensible through
a phone changes your style.
JOHN LINNELL: I
mean, that dovetails
into what we're talking about.
Because I think it
influenced-- we've probably
said this in the past.
It influenced our writing style,
that the Dial-A-Song machine
was the most restrictive,
in terms of bandwidth.
And there were even sounds
you couldn't make in the song
because they would trigger
the automatic rewind
of the machine.
So it was a very,
very good discipline.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: If there
is a long, sustained note,
it would basically
make it reject.
So we would even get
into doing a thing that's
almost like a DJ thing.
If there was like, I want
to know, it would be like,
I want to "kno-oh-oh-oh-oh."
Because that would allow
it to keep on working.
JOHN LINNELL: Plus, in order
for the lyrics to be audible--
and this is another
thing that we've always
been kind of uptight
about, making
sure you can hear the words,
rather than have it be sort of,
a what did he say?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: A vibe.
JOHN LINNELL: A vibe, right.
This was another thing
about the Dial-A-Song,
the arrangement
couldn't be too fussy.
And because we automatically
liked doing fussy arrangements,
we had to reel that in.
So it's had a huge
influence on the way
that we write ever since then.
And I think we still feel
like simpler works better.
AUDIENCE: Are the laptop
speakers doing the same thing?
JOHN LINNELL: Sorry,
the laptop speaker?
Yeah.
I mean, and like I
said, I just like
a controlled amount of
bandwidth when I'm listening.
So I think it's all of a piece.
This whole aesthetic
is kind of connected.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
And the opposite
that's happening
with most people
is that they're on ear buds.
And that can be a very
full-frequency experience, much
more than hi-fis ever were.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN LINNELL: Thanks.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Thank you.
AARON ZEMACH: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I started listening
to you guys when
I was growing up in
a place that didn't
get much alternative anything.
And it was awesome and
freeing and opened my mind
to this whole
underground alternative,
not what everyone else was
listening to and doing world.
And OK, A, thank you so much
and you totally changed my life
and made it.
And B, you're still
involved with a lot
of experimental and
cutting edge and not
mainstream or not-yet-mainstream
people and acts and artists.
How do you find those
people to collaborate with,
and where do you get
your influences from?
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Well, I can answer--
I mean, in terms of the
video collaboration process,
it is very curatorial.
A lot of times, we'll
simply ask people
we've worked with before
if they know of anybody.
So it sort of
spreads out that way.
And we also do these video
contests, which is a--
it's a strange thing
in the culture.
Because when you post a contest,
you immediately get responses
from angry artists
who are like, artists
should be paid for their work
and these contests are just
ways of ripping artists off.
And I'm very sensitive
to that idea, in a way.
But unfortunately, I'm too busy
writing for a Ford commercial
for free to worry
so much about it.
Because it is part of being
in the creative community,
that the audition never stops.
And it is absolutely
frustrating.
It never stops
being frustrating.
And I completely understand
people being upset about it.
But the truth is,
through these contests,
we find tons of people that
we end up working with.
We actually-- the current
contest that we have going,
there are three winners.
And we'll probably make other
videos with all three of them
because whatever they do will
probably be very interesting
and cool stuff.
And it's just a way
for us to find more.
I mean, we've got 52
weeks to program, so.
AARON ZEMACH: It's
funny because I realized
I forgot to mention that
many years ago, I actually
was a winner of a They Might
Be Giants video contest.
JOHN LINNELL: No way.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: You're kidding.
AARON ZEMACH: I forgot
to say that, yeah.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Which one?
AARON ZEMACH: For Omaha,
the Omaha venue song.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Oh, right, right.
But are you from Omaha?
AARON ZEMACH: I'm
not from Omaha.
No, sorry.
But we did end up
collaborating eventually.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: There you go.
JOHN LINNELL: Wow, that's great.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have a question
from a friend who
introduced me to you guys
when I was very little.
He's been listening to
you for his whole life.
So he's curious about your
song "A Self Called Nowhere."
If the lyric goes, "it's a thing
named id at the bottomless pit"
or "it's a thing named it
at the bottomless pit",
and if it's a
psychological reference.
JOHN LINNELL: I can
answer that in a word.
It's "it," which rhymes
with "pit," of course.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, of course.
JOHN LINNELL: And I
also want to point out,
we haven't been playing that
song for the last 20 years.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I
would say 20 years.
JOHN LINNELL: We will be
playing it on our next tour.
We just decided to
re-introduce it.
Just by coincidence, we
are pulling that one out
and we're going to be
playing it on the tour.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: And
we'll be enunciating "it."
JOHN LINNELL: That's right.
I'll be very clear
in my pronunciation.
AUDIENCE: I'll be
sure to tell him that.
AARON ZEMACH: You
just ended, like,
40 very vitriolic
internet conversations
that have been going
on for decades.
JOHN LINNELL: Or was it "it"?
Maybe not.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I
thought everyone here
had a nondisclosure thing?
AARON ZEMACH: So is this
a question over here?
Great.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you guys talked
a bit about liking
to be on the bleeding
edge of technology
and using new technologies.
I'm wondering if there's
any new technologies you've
seen or heard of floating around
now that you haven't gotten
to take advantage of
yet that you'd like to?
JOHN LINNELL: I don't think
we've used the word bleeding
edge actually.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah,
that's tougher than we are.
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah, we're
more like just near the edge.
We're not getting hurt.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: This is going
to sound incredibly spaced
out because it's a
really spaced-out idea,
but I was having a conversation
with Pete in our office
about this yesterday.
Like a lot of people who do
Kickstarter campaigns or do--
being in the arts these
days requires a lot of--
there are a lot of patronage
schemes that people do.
And we started a
thing a few years back
called the Instant Fan
Club, where basically, we
had been in the studio
for six months longer
than we were planning on.
We hadn't been on the road.
We just were completely
broke and we actually
had to pay a lot of bills.
So we thought,
let's do some kind
of pre-sale for this
record, even though it's not
going to be out for
three or four months,
and at least we won't
be broke right now.
So we started this thing
called the Instant Fan
Club and pre-sold 5,000
records, and promised
a bunch of other stuff, and
made it a really good value
for the people who joined it.
And ever since then, we've
periodically had these Instant
Fan Club things.
And it'll be just
really good deals.
It's like a bundled thing.
You get like $200 worth of
stuff for $100 or whatever.
And a lot of times, there's
music exclusives in there.
And I was trying to figure out--
in Britain, you do not
have to get permission
to have your recordings played.
You have to grant permission
to have your recordings played
on the radio.
It is not compulsory that if
you put a record or a recording
into the world that the
radio gets to play it.
There's still this moment of
almost fine art possession,
like this thing exists, and
only the artists themselves
can determine where it goes.
And I was wondering--
this is really on the cutting
edge of intellectual property
question--
would there be a way to
not publish your music,
but simply create a disk
or create a unique piece
of reproduced music like a CD?
And I think of the--
what was that thing that the
creepy pharma dude bought?
AARON ZEMACH:
Wu-Tang Clan album.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I
mean, I was wondering,
are those compositions at BMI?
I would assume not.
But they sold it like
a piece of fine art,
rather than a piece
of commercial art.
And I'm wondering, could
we actually pull out
of the commercial marketplace
and create just fine art music
for our benefactors?
JOHN LINNELL: For oligarchs.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
And does anybody here
know that pharma dude guy?
AUDIENCE: Not personally.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Anyway,
those are my racing thoughts.
JOHN LINNELL: That's a
horrible new trend that--
JOHN FLANSBURGH: The
pharma dude thing?
JOHN LINNELL: Just the idea that
everything is for rich people.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Well, I'm not saying
it should be for rich people.
I'm just saying it would be
interesting to just not have
it be something that
immediately goes to--
you know, I love the
streaming services.
But I'm telling
you, the checks--
JOHN LINNELL: It's killing us.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah.
JOHN LINNELL: Hello.
AUDIENCE: It was
interesting to hear
that your early, early
performances were
in these performance art
clubs in the East Village,
because your early shows
also had definitely
an aspect of
performance art to them.
Like, the huge hats as
megaphones, and the sets
were pretty bizarre for
concerts at that time.
JOHN LINNELL: We were
forced to do that stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
wondering, how much of that
was that influence?
And it seemed like that sort
of dropped out of your concert
structure more recently.
At least, your concerts
don't feel as much
like bizarre performance art
as they did in the early days.
And I was wondering if
that was intentional
or that was just sort
of how it evolved
with the music evolving?
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
Well, we evolved.
We worked as a duo for 10 years.
And over the course of that
time, there was sort of like--
some prop stuff
moved into the act.
I think probably the
biggest difference
between what we were doing
and what a "regular" rock
band was doing is that we were
working with a drum machine.
So in some ways, the props
might have been compensating,
on a theatrical
level, for what was
missing by having an exciting,
live drummer to watch.
I mean, the thing that
I reflect on back then
is how committed we were to
the idea of the drum machine.
For a lot of people,
I realize now,
working with a drum machine
is a complete wrong answer,
like that's never
going to be good.
But at the time
I think we really
felt like, we are
just rocking so hard,
and this drum machine
is so excellent.
JOHN LINNELL: It didn't
feel like a-- it wasn't
a compromise.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: It did not
feel like a compromise at all.
AUDIENCE: The whole "Rhythm
Section Want Ad" song
sort of captured that.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Exactly.
JOHN LINNELL:
You're reminding me,
I think our very earliest
shows, before we started
doing these East Village
performance places,
we were playing in
showcase-y clubs,
trying to be like-- we played
at CBGB as a showcase band.
And we were totally using
the props and stuff there.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Oh, sure.
Yeah.
JOHN LINNELL: So
it wasn't because--
it was more like we found
another place where we'd
fit in, basically, was how we
ended up in the East Village
thing.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: But
we stopped using them
when it became something that
people expected, basically.
Like, if it's the first
time you've seen a band,
and they do this thing
that's got this really
weird theatrical thing to it,
it's like, that's interesting.
But as soon as it's like,
oh, bring out the thing
and it becomes this sort
of "Rocky Horror Picture"
tradition thing,
it was just like--
and that really
happened the second time
we toured the United States.
And just suddenly, we
became this like straight,
no chaser, like two
guys, drum machine,
that's all you're getting.
JOHN LINNELL: Right.
Say the catch phrase.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Play
number three again.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Thank you.
AARON ZEMACH: Do
you feel like that's
something you're actively
fighting against,
like the mythos traditions
of They Might Be Giants is
something on your mind?
JOHN LINNELL: I don't know.
I think in some ways, we want
to keep the spirit alive.
The original-- you
know, we're always
trying to get back
to the impulse
that we started with with this.
But as John said, we
don't want to keep
using the same
vocabulary over and over.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
There is a weird thing
about how bands kind of
turn on themselves, in terms
of if something is
successful for them.
They're like, that's the only
thing they don't want to do.
I think you have to
really avoid that.
It's sort of a grumpy thing that
we definitely want to not do.
AARON ZEMACH: Totally.
AUDIENCE: So with so many years
of making music and having
this giant repertoire,
are there any songs
that you've sort of gotten
sick of and are like,
I just never want
to play that again?
JOHN LINNELL: Absolutely, yes.
AUDIENCE: Which ones?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Do we
have to say which ones?
Because we're
contractually obligated--
no, no.
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah,
well, they come and go.
I think there's some
that we've played
a lot that we get tired of.
And then there's always the
option of rediscovering stuff.
So I think that's a nice thing.
We have a big enough repertoire
that we can shuffle things
in and out.
Weirdly, though, I think
we still kind of generally
like our early material.
JOHN FLANSBURGH:
There are definitely
songs we don't have to rehearse.
JOHN LINNELL: That's fun.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: It's fun
not rehearsing those songs.
And it is also fun--
the energy you get
back from an audience
when you're playing
a popular song--
I saw a recent film of The
Rolling Stones, and wow.
But I have to say--
JOHN LINNELL: That's
a positive wow, right?
JOHN FLANSBURGH: --they're
still playing "Satisfaction,"
which just seems crazy to me,
especially since they said they
wouldn't.
They promised.
AARON ZEMACH: Over here.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask
you about your kids albums,
actually.
I've been a fan of you
guys since college,
and I bought "Flood"
on cassette even.
And so it was great fun
to be able to introduce
the band to my kid.
And he was a big fan
of "Here Come the ABCs"
and "Here Come the 123s."
And I just wanted to hear
about what inspired that
and what's happening there.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: It's a
curious thing doing kid stuff
because you're kind of
immediately declaring
that you're a nicer person
than you might actually be.
[LAUGHTER]
We are guys who were in a rock
band, an alternative rock band,
at a time when you could
be extremely selfish.
And doing kid stuff,
it's like you really have
to be extraordinarily nice.
JOHN LINNELL: Well
you should say, like,
that's on behalf of the parents.
The kids actually like
the mean attitude.
And they like the swearing,
I just want to say.
The parents do not
like the swearing.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Kids
love the swearing.
JOHN LINNELL: Yes.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: But
there's sort of like a--
writing kids' music is a
really great open invitation
to just write about anything.
It is an enormous trampoline to
jump on and just write a song.
You talk about, how do you
keep writing new songs?
Having the opportunity
to write for kids,
I think, in many
ways, really got
us revved up again about
the whole writing process.
Because there's no sense of--
no rock critic is going
to talk about your work
when you're writing
a kids' song.
You're really just writing
for yourself and the audience.
And so it's just a very
kind of lovely scenario.
But doing kids' shows is
something else entirely.
And it's very hard to
mediate the demands of--
like, there are people--
when we do a kids'
show, we find out
right away that it is both too
long and too short, and much
too loud and much too quiet.
So it's a strangely--
for something that
seems like it could--
it's just complicated.
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah, kids
don't know what they want.
That's the problem.
So they're impossible to please.
AUDIENCE: And you guys,
I'd like to thank you
on behalf of many parents
for making a lot of long car
journeys more tolerable.
JOHN LINNELL: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's something we
could all listen to and enjoy.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: They
are designed for that.
JOHN LINNELL: Sure, absolutely.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Thank you.
AARON ZEMACH: So
before we wrap up,
I just have one more question.
You mentioned "Self
Called Nowhere"
is going to come
back on this tour.
You're looking at other
songs in the catalog.
Is there any song,
in particular,
that you're excited to be
playing on the upcoming tour,
maybe that you haven't
played in a while?
JOHN LINNELL: Well, I
would say that we've
got a lot of new material
that we're really
thrilled to be introducing.
I mean, for me, that's
the funnest thing,
is the new stuff.
JOHN FLANSBURGH: I'm
super psyched about just
working with Curt Ramm,
our trumpet player,
and having long
car rides to talk
about politics with our band.
That's-- yelling at the TV.
JOHN LINNELL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: Great.
Well, so very excited
to see you on this tour,
and thanks again to John
Linnell and John Flansburgh
for coming out [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN FLANSBURGH: Thanks.
JOHN LINNELL: Thanks
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]